some people in this modern era of
filmmaking there's a lot of product
placement and a lot of indie films use
product placement cuz you can get a lot
of money were you tempted to do that any
part yeah well we were trying it when we
were trying to raise the money we looked
into product placement and we had a
dildo company offer us $50,000 because
there's a scene where my character has a
sexual awakening moment by myself they
offered us fifty thousand dollars to use
their dildo and that's seen fifty
thousand bottoms yeah but we didn't want
a dildo to be in the scene at all it was
about how she finds like her own there
trying to jam a dildo into a scene where
it doesn't belong ridiculous that's like
oh it's the scene of The Sound of Music
where she's teaching the kids and he
could be using it masturbating in the
scene so but there wasn't supposed to be
a dildo your your your okay you are
pleasuring yourself masturbating I think
it's the medical term and you and so
they want to do it is their name on the
dildo how would anyone know is there
dilly they were gonna give us money to
put it I thought it was your courage was
to go like there's nothing like a
Foster's dildo
foster's means quality mics dildo take
it from Mike hey I make the best
Wow
okay well here's a question you are the
director of the film hmm there's a scene
where you said that you are must be
adults here masturbating and how do you
direct yourself in a scene like that
well it's very weird because you know
I'm like laying in bed and there's a
camera guy standing over me holding the
camera right so it's it's very strange
yeah yeah so and you okay I don't know
what to even go but it just seems like a
moment where you'd be thinking how like
how did this become what I'm doing right
now that's true I did have a moment but
look I was trying to tell story about a
woman who goes through sexual repression
then she falls in love with this guy is
not good for her she hasn't a sexual
awakening moment and then the final
masturbation scene is showing she finds
that beautiful sexual energy inside
herself without a man she knows that she
can be happy independently what is the
reaction been from guys who've seen the
film has anyone given you any critical
notes like I changed this or change that
well I have a scene where they go to a
class and the women are chanting I love
my [ __ ] and my friend saw the scene and
he said oh I'm very offended you need to
change it - I love my flower why
offensive to have women saying I love my
[ __ ] that it's offensive but no I well
first of all men are just piping up I
don't think people yeah it's not his
business yeah I know exactly it's not
his business and if my flower that's
actually gross
soon my precious well then I went to the
women's March and everyone is screaming
[ __ ] at the women's March right and
everywhere it's it's it's taken over the
nation it's y'all good at me when I was
a kid all right
you